we're not protestors where water
protectors we are indigenous we have
been here since time immemorial
we are not protesters I'm not violent we
are protectors the term protesters is a
colonized term for standing up for
what's right
we're out here protecting this land
because it's everything to us because it
would be a continuation of the policies
towards Native people which is
destruction of land destruction of water
the Dakota access pipeline wants to
think that this is business as usual
it's not just about Native people but
it's about the 18 million people that
depend on the Missouri River and that
are downstream from us as well this
isn't a pipeline
this is fossil fuel infrastructure for
profits not for the people you can't
guarantee that this pipeline is not
going to break you can't guarantee any
of that and we have to help stop it it
jeopardizes too many people's water
disrespect to our spirituality our
language is founded upon the land what
we are trying to say is that America
this is a wake up call
it's just a part of the extractive
economy and it's a part of another
aspect of the violence that we as
indigenous peoples have been
experiencing for over 500 years
[Music]